[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the old barbie room this is our daily
show that keeps you updated on just
what's happening in barbie news
i am hosting today
um which feels very strange um but
coming up on the show
of course we have barbie watch
uh we also have
christian bale and natalie portman
dishing secrets about thor love and
thunder some of us at the table may have
seen the movie already most of us have
not missed marvel episode four
predictions are happening today and we
have some really kind of crazy bonkers
kenobi news about like potentially
future movies or episodes or seasons
we don't know there's a lot to talk
about i'm so happy to be joined by one
of our great researchers here at new
rockstars anna vansten hi i can't stop
where's my camera i need my camera it's
just me it's getting there we go i can't
stop staring at john's thighs they look
like cameras oh no so good
and of course also with me in l.a is koi
jindro very excited to be here i'm
excited for all the barbie news that's
fit to print and that ken look is
inspiring some bad choices up here that
i might have to adopt
he looks so good baby goose has never
looked better
please we're all a little too thirsty
today
i love the horny energy we're bringing
to this channel right now place beyond
the pines was barbie's house all along
that's a great really point but he looks
just like it it's just like he got
cleaned up out got out of prison and
joined the barbie madness i would love i
would love
a barbie movie where ken is just a
freaking monster
robbing banks and crashing his
motorcycle i love that but i maintain
that drive is just the sequel to lars
and the real girl so i'd like there to
be one big ryan gosling shared gosling
continuity because like he's all quiet
and stoic and it's like i lost my girl
and now i drive i love them
pat nelson is a prequel to drive and
lars the real girl
wait okay which ryan which riot which
mcu future character that we haven't
seen yet would you cat who's like the
broody
sort of like writing the obvious answer
is mr scott summers oh that would be
very funny if they go the age where he's
a teacher i'd get some ryan gosling if
they go younger i'd go glenn powell if
they go with jason i'd go maybe like a
justin hartley you've got we were
talking before the show coy just put out
a video yesterday on the real rejects
channel
about dr doom and his future in the mcu
uh if you liked our dr doom video
yesterday go check out his he we were
talking before the show about all of
your doom
casting ideas i won't spoil them here
unless you want to go did you did you
say like read wizard growing up like
wizard magazine i didn't so wizard
magazine was like uh like a tv guide for
comic books so they had like a price
guide in the back they had all the big
news and so there was always like a fan
casting and there was also like the big
ten writers and artists so all those
wretched artists became like celebrities
to me cause you'd see their little faces
like brian k vaughan and jim lee so to
this day when i see them in a con i'm
like oh my god it's blob and like
everyone else is chill and i'm like i
can handle tom cruise
you can just show up and see all the
people that you love and everyone was
like who's that guy like all the yeah
all the last names in person you're like
oh my god but like the fan casting was
always inspired me because i was a movie
guy and a comic guy so once i started
fan casting like through these networks
and shows we do so my big four for
doctor doom to tease the video you
should check out the rest because they
talk about how to bring in doctor doom
what story lines where i think he'll
come in how he'd shape the mcu but the
the casting i thought the best one i
think is michael shannon i think
michael's trying to be an incredible
ominous promoting his voice coming out
of that helmet i really really think
that the incredible viggo mortensen i
know he's on the older side but like he
just gets a voice he just gets to have
that power i really love goron visnik
look his name up he's awesome he's got
that like european charm and flavor
going about them and then i think my
last one would be i forget what my last
one was i told you when i showed you the
guy from a knife rufus
he's got the eyes he's got the intensity
he's got the charm he's got the
arrogance he's got the nest he's got the
height he's rupa's soul is my fourth
you would think that with three people
instead of four we could stay more on
track and like really
we gotta we gotta wrangle it in also we
have our uh our uh what do you call the
swear jar the reverse swear jar where uh
we'll give you
a few swears if we get to every every
hundred you know every hundred mark a
couple and and on every 100 mark i will
commit to putting on an additional layer
on my upper body and hiking my shorts
yes oh my god
i want short shorts incentive that's the
actual reason to go forward let's get
them
i want ken's short shorts by the end of
this please please do this for me you're
in both you get not only swearing but
also potentially pg-13 plus
but first okay okay okay we're gonna get
down to business we have headlines today
yeah just hit it i'm in charge because
i'm the big papa i get to read the
headlines so first up we have the doctor
strange multiverse of madness reached
2.1 million u.s households on disney
plus in his first five days which breaks
the viewership record how do you feel
it's really interesting to me right that
breaks a disney plus viewership record
which i think includes you know
movies like
uh soul
and and you know so those big pixar
movies that are huge for families that
only dropped on disney plus right this
is just for people who are like i see a
movie again yeah even chongqi had less
views in five days than a multiverse of
madness so that's it i'll give it up for
them and then of course what everyone's
just dying to hear the news about i've
been waiting for anyone we can't we
can't we can't it is the bbw we couldn't
think of a better acronym the perfect
acronym aka
break room barbie watch uh and we are
here to report on the new barbie set
pics that we got that just dropped let's
see them let's see them
look how goofy they are oh my god i love
it i love the 90s you guys they're fresh
out of the package like you can see them
they just opened a really good point
all of my nostalgia feels we also in
some of the pictures there was a will
ferrell who that was out of complete
left field so much for i love this for
several reasons first of all almost all
black of course villain vibes but the
pink tie is just cracking up they got to
keep it in there
um and so what do what what is will
ferrell doing in this movie i mean it
looks like he's chasing the great barbie
in canada because they're also in roller
skates i feel like there's a chase afoot
a skate here's something i noticed
in one of the uh in one of the promo
vids that came out it is barbie roller
skating and she's like come on you hear
her voice for the first time and then
there's a promo video well no no no it's
one of those fan ones that have been
releasing yeah nothing official but
she's like come on let's go have fun and
then there are two
normos women who are skating after her
and like yeah let's go me thinks that
will pharaoh will will pharaoh uh will
ferrell and this rando lady who's with
barbie it might be like a um a life-size
situation where they have a tie
and uh and she's barbie needs to teach
this ordinary plain peasant woman some
sort of life lesson in order to complete
her life but will
feral pharaoh who knows who knows
scientists and the scientists still
don't know uh is after her for some for
whatever reason i feel like there's
gonna be like an elf situation but he's
he's not elf like i feel like you know
they're trying to stifle the magic of
barbie and ken so will ferrell gets to
play the straight man to barbie and
ken's exuberance and he's trying to
stifle their neon glory he's trying to
temper the 90s out how dare he honestly
may i say the one the picture that
really sold it for me it wasn't in the
most recent batch that came out but the
one that really did it for me was when
she was in her pink cowboy suit hair
down to her ass it was like oh
barbie yes i can't wait to see the cars
the accessories we know we got simo liu
we've got so many ken's like we've got
ken other types so what if we like what
if ken gets kidnapped or something what
if will ferrell gets it i got a question
i want to hear all your barbie hot takes
in in chat too leave your barbie hot
takes as to what you think it's going to
be about what you're thinking about the
costumes uh everything like that because
that's all we care about here i'm
telling you
where on the internet are people getting
at least 15 minutes of barbie talk every
weekend no way nowhere nowhere you can
only get it on
a bunch of new rock stars
the influences barbie youtube channel um
uh we're going to cover this movie like
it's goddamn adventures in gaming you
can't stop us philip
that's why he's not here
elsewhere phillip molina is the will
farrell of our movie when we're where
we're barbie and kids trying to stifle
our neon and that's the problem damn it
god damn it philip but unfortunately we
do have to move on to other headlines
so
much more boringly natalie portman
sorry had to cut entire planets from the
new thor love and thunder film she goes
on to mention the interview that tyka
has such a wide imagination so much
brilliance and material that a lot of it
ends up not in there it hits the cutting
room floor uh you've seen it so you know
do you have any opinions on what planets
may or may not have we've sort of
alluded to that in the title and the
thumbnail of this video we're going to
get into it a little bit later we did
just see you know we're trying to keep
some of this a little bit vague in case
people want to go in with a little more
blindness than than
you know
watching every single teaser like we
have to but there was a new teaser that
came out today with the guardians of the
galaxy on a planet we hadn't seen them
on before or at least it looked like
that to me so i think this movie um our
next story is kind of going to talk
about taika talking about the multiverse
i think this movie is going to be you
know just a planet hopper rather than a
multiverse hopper and we're just going
to kind of be everywhere i feel like i
can say carefully that uh they film this
in the void like they oh sure so i think
it's really interesting in just talking
about creative process
tyka's void but i think the creative
process he's talked uh about his format
for filming is he kind of finds the
movie in the editing room he kind of
shapes it after so i love the idea of
the freedom of that kind of improv
exuberance just getting to make make
make and having the budget to go crazy
and then the assembly cut was apparently
four hours and that is normal that is
how movies work don't go lobbying for
the release the taika cut that's not a
movie that's just like things they shot
that were multiple takes but it's
interesting to see them kind of like
hone in on what version they want to
sculpt out of four hours and i think
that we are entering an age where that's
going to be more and more common where
with the void you don't have to change
locations you don't have to physically
move your cast you don't have to fly
them you can just make and i think that
pure creativity like that is going to
spawn a lot more taika types and a lot
more of this mad energy that's only
going to benefit the genre that is this
comic book world well speaking of barbie
do we think that guardians of the galaxy
are going to show up in the barbie movie
because i can't wait
to say something about the void in the
barbie-like world you could totally film
an infinite number of barbie verses oh
yeah i will i do want to shout out all
of our great super chatters yes uh we
did cross that country
yes
polls are in uh anna gets to swear you
can do it however you'd like i'm going
to go put on a new layer and get my
i needed my mic too early put on another
layer hike up my shorts oh are we going
to hear through the mic
the sound of little clothing
i'm just wondering what he's going to
put on he has more layers how many
layers
it's deeply due if you wouldn't mind
like super chatting a little bit more so
you can see how many layers john has
we're confused like i don't know how he
has more because he's already wearing a
sweater we might have to donate
all right what kind of sweat i almost
feel like you should get this aware
since you're you're you're one of the
guests okay do you want to get this you
can swear at people in chat you can
swear at me you can swear joyously to
the universe
you're pulling it off it's beautifully
thematically thorough let me see this
short let me see those though okay
little it's a tasteful amount right now
there it is there it is
now careful we might break 200.
yeah you got to remember here's more
like kermit the frog oh man best
impression please
and swear in it oh he should get the
swear
swear i used to have a really good
kermit some no i'm not i can't remember
mr frog here oh
that's very helpful someday we'll find
this the [ __ ]
rainbow
you could have just replaced rainbow
with [ __ ] but you were like nah
the [ __ ] connection [ __ ]
connections the lovers the
dreamers
i love it we should probably actually
read these super chats that way i can't
see the ones on the left side of the
screen so soulgasm oh yeah says thank
you for blessing us with awesome content
we have a couple of super nice uh non
chats but
donations and stickers from cruiser and
it's zonta zanti put us over the edge
mine thank you so much half your thyroid
you're amazing that you i owe you a are
you a
second thigh
you feel like
um should we continue with the headlines
and circle back to some cheaper let's do
it so speaking of the multiverse in thor
love and thunder a taiko watiti
confirmed there are no multiverse
shenanigans happening in the movie he
says we got nothing like that in this
film this is the singular verse i think
that's really interesting right um we've
talked a lot about on this channel about
sort of like the earthbound stories and
the cosmic stories and it looked like
all the sort of cosmic stories were
going multiverse and the earthbound
stories were going to go like singular
verse but now it's kind of splitting
right you've got doctor strange and
spiderman in new york and those are the
multiverse stories and then we've got
this great you know sort of
space opera happening with the guardians
and and they're like no we're just going
to do 616. and it's going to be a blast
honestly i feel like if i had just come
off of making multiverse of madness i
would just be like mentally exhausted
like too tired to be like i don't want
any other universes just do the one
universe yeah kevin kevin feige is like
we figure it out
can we reuse some of them or something i
feel like we're gonna look back i feel
like phase four is a lot like phase one
but with phase one we've had the benefit
of phase two and three to look back on
to them like retroactively tying things
in together yeah i feel like phase four
is much more coherent than people like
there's a lot of people mad that it
feels like aimless and things but if you
look at phase one until we knew avengers
and what it actually would be we only
knew that they knew each other it was a
lot of post-credits scene so i'm really
curious with the tva and the kang of it
all if there's hang of it the king of it
all the title of my future autobiography
the king of it all the anime if we're
gonna go like oh and like see all these
things as like i wonder if it's
intentional like if you know what what
tyke is saying here enough whatever it's
intentional that it feels like every
other and all those things but what
shocked me most is that they came out
and said
something that clear and cut you know
two weeks before release sure because i
felt like i couldn't talk about this
movie for two weeks now they're coming
out and saying stuff so it's like oh at
least i can breathe i got no trouble at
all
no but i i do think like that
we were talking about stakes earlier in
the office earlier and how it's hard to
do stakes when you have a multiverse
right like okay reed richards died in dr
strange in the multiverse of madness
that's okay that's okay we're going to
get him again
right and and of course that movie sort
of played it for horror or comedy or
whichever side of the camp you're on but
um
you know it it does introduce new
problems of being able to you know say
we can replace anyone whenever we want
to and in the comics that led to heroes
reborn in the return one of the greatest
things that i've ever had in a comic
book uh it is a problem when you have
this you know kind of infallibility when
you have this infinite reset code and in
the comic books they've historically had
to reset entire universes at dc they did
crises multiple times and marvel they
had to start the ultimate universe then
they problematically collided the
ultimate universe with our universe
which caused incursion events which
they're now doing in movies and i don't
think that's a coincidence that as we
reach these zeniths we have the issue of
trying to make them all work in
streamline but i do think we do have the
benefit of learning from those
overpopulated issues and kevin feige
being a comic book fan i think he can
choose the now that's what i call
greatest hits of comic books and make it
work i do just worry the ambition might
cloud the day-to-day viewers experience
like it might be too much yeah they are
i will say they are doing a really good
job of introducing these concepts to
you know general movie audiences who
maybe haven't read you know hundreds of
issues of comics but uh it will be
interesting because you're right i'm
sure they're all very aware of the
problems that they're introducing and
they i'm sure know exactly how they're
going to solve them in 10 years because
you know like feige's clearly like a 90s
guy like a lot of the comics he pulls
from are very much that 90s era and
that's when you started to get these
problems so it's like he learned from
that era which caused a lot of the bloat
of comic books and the 2000s really
saved comic books and it's crazy that
the 2008 model was right after they kind
of found themselves again and that's
when these movies started so what
they're taking from is already kind of
the greatest hits of if you look at the
ultimate universe that's what spider-man
pulled from 60 years of comics into 10
and they're using that as a bit of a
model the ultimates is the more
cinematic version of vendors they're
using that as a model but eventually
they're going to run out of that and
they're going to have to go classic like
loki they're going to have to look at
these things that are different times
and i'm wondering if we're going to have
a big old reboot and a big reset in the
films once they become as big as the
comics are i can also see a world where
we talked about this a little bit on
yesterday's show but we didn't get into
this aspect of it where like
we just are with other characters in a
different universe and you're doing 616
stuff but you're also doing stuff in a
new
universe that maybe hasn't been
introduced in either comics or in films
and we're just hanging out over here and
if you look at the phase four we have
today you've got you know the the phase
one was
meeting everyone phase two is not
trusting your organizations and your
governments and phase three was not
trusting your heroes phase four is
introducing mythology we've got the
field of reads and moon knight we've got
the eternals we've got uh everything
that we're seeing in miss marvel with
the gin it's building out but it's not
really letting you live with them too
much because it's introducing the next
thing the next thing the next thing and
i think that's intentional i think
there's gonna be a cataclysmic event
that wipes out a lot of stuff at the end
of phase four and i think that's kang
ooh i like that i i i
billion degrees in los angeles today and
i have two sweaters on so i'm gonna zip
through this show i don't know why i
keep going for sweaters
is there a ken tank top back there i
don't think so um this is our sort of uh
a headliner topic today um there was a
bunch of cool creepy stuff that made it
into thor love and thunder but we're
also hearing that there was a bunch of
cool creepy stuff that didn't make it in
to thor love and thunder in a recent
interview christian bale had with
collider he mentioned that there was a
bunch of hilarious gold but also creepy
as hell stuff that didn't end up making
it into the film and he says that it's
because it wouldn't have been
family friendly and if you sort of read
between the lines there
you can sort of you know hypothesize
that that means they were afraid of
getting too close to an r rating right
christian bell was like we always
intended this to be sort of a film that
everyone could go see and we had to cut
some things or change some things so
that that could be the case so um i
suppose like
coy you've seen this film uh do you want
to sort of walk us through not not going
to the film perhaps but like you were we
were talking earlier about you know
here's maybe where they could have
pulled from from the comics to make gore
as sort of r-rated as possible and maybe
they would have had to sort of dial the
comics available for five years now so
not a spoiler for a movie out in 10 days
uh god bomb is a really really intense
great story that is i would argue
bordering r-rated yeah and all gods must
die is kind of gore's whole thing so he
says it in the trailer and you feel that
inclination for you know the character
himself he's gore the god butcher those
aren't a series of words that are
typically pg-13 so in the comic books i
could easily see if they had been more
uh
in tuned with certain parts of certain
storylines it could have been that and
it sounds like they might have shot
those and then just realized like hey
that might not be like we said the four
hour cut down to the two hour cut it
might have just not fit with what they
wanted as the end result but i'd be very
curious to see on a blu-ray on the
special features on any of these things
if there is a version of that and again
not to snyder cut everything but what
does it look like when you know tyke has
got the actual book in his hand he's
making that story yeah and like what
does that mean for you know the the
evolution of the next thing because i i
personally love that comic books are so
different from the movies like even
civil war is a vastly different thing
than its namesake so the more version
probably yeah there's going to be that
because people have enough characters
for that really but i think it's really
important to not do translations but to
do adaptations and i think that in doing
an adaptation of god bomb in these
stories that involve gore you get to
surprise comic fans as well as make it
more approachable for people that
haven't read 70 years of thor and i
think that marvel does a really good job
again picking the best of that stuff
while keeping it to the audience that
they're looking at which as christian
says here not me is more family friendly
i feel you snipers i see
i see uh soulgasm dropped a kane gang uh
comment in the chat that's a classic mt
uh catchphrase and and to tie empty into
this conversation if you're not um film
you're familiar with god bomb and that
run in the comics i believe mt has a
video out on the channel about that if
not i think it's coming soon uh we have
we have
so many videos that we put on this
channel it's hard to keep track of
what's out and what's in the pipeline
but um go check that out if you're not
super familiar anna my question for you
i'm ignoring cory for a minute you're
also ignoring what i was about to say
what are you going to say i was just
going to say i don't mind having those
be separate movies
they had announced from the beginning
that this was going to be a little more
lighthearted a little more family
friendly great keep at that then give me
this really dark
um and
and yeah i want i i want all the dark
stuff in one all the dark horror and one
and then you can have this fun little
thing over here and i will say and i
think this wouldn't get me in trouble
that gore is terrifying like like you
can tell from the trailers like gore is
gore from the comic book so i don't want
this quote or anything that are you know
in talking about the movie it's a very
intense character and i think i can also
safely say that like he makes my
rushmore of marvel villains like he's so
and that's i've you know lived these
movies so it is
not at a disservice to the character
sure
i don't want him doing a musical number
um
what i was going to ask you
uh sorry you've seen oh no i've said a
lot answer this question
um there's sort of two ways you can go
with like a really great villain right
you can go creepy scary like creepy
scary or you can go violent scary and
and
do you have an expectation right like or
the god butcher makes me think violent
yeah but they've been talking about
creepy for for in a lot of these
interviews that's maybe we'll get both
maybe i think i feel like wanda from
multiverse of madness was a great
mixture of both like she had that creepy
factor at all times with just like how
much she had lost it like lost sight of
what was important but then she also had
these incredibly violent parts that was
like whoa
when i don't know i would suspect
gore to go in the more violent thanos
route but he does just kind of naturally
look real creepy huh he does look real
creepy he says real creepy things
like all of the little one-liners that
he's given in trailers have been like
you're freaking out
do you feel that it goes farther than
wanda
i feel that
gore is a more
oh man this is a hard line to walk you
just want to make it i feel like a
lawyer i'm like
i feel like you write your answer yeah
just like let me prep i feel that they
both do a very good job doing what the
comics do which is using the medium to
creatively keep themselves in a pg-13
place that's a great non-answer i love
that
learning from papa foggy what the heck
here's here's the answer that you here's
a question that you can't answer uh this
is not an r-rated film right this is a
pg-13 rated film um
but we keep getting these movies that
are sort of pushing the r rating
boundary multiverse of madness we just
talked about what will
uh i'm going to hold you in an answer on
this what will be marvel's first r-rated
film you cannot say deadpool but yeah
okay i i think if blade goes the tv
route it'll push the tvma boundary that
daredevil did you think they might they
might say blade's gonna be issues but i
i can't like i don't know anything
beyond that announcement at phase four
which was very vague and purpose i think
and we've sort of heard the things that
we can't substantiate so we don't report
on the show that the the the shooting of
that movie has sort of been pushed
recently
and that's what's tricky is like when
you announce something as big as phase
four that intentionally doesn't have an
ending if you notice when you look at
the phase four slate there's no like and
this will wrap up with blank it is very
much this and i think that's the big
thing kevin feige's been teasing he kept
saying like soon you'll know where this
is going soon this will be this yeah i
think we're getting a big big tease at
san diego comic-con and then i think
we're getting what concludes phase four
at d23 i think this thing is i think
this is the infinity war in game of
announcements i think we're getting a
one-two punch i think i think within the
next three months september we're gonna
know what phase four culminates in and i
think then we'll know what blade's gonna
be and i do think if there's a character
beyond deadpool because i see it in bold
uh that is rated it is the incredible
blade character that kind of started the
mcu i know spider-man x may get the
credit but if you re-watch those blade
movies they do such a good job of doing
what the mcu does in phase three they
they are truly movies that happen to be
based off a character like blade wesley
snipes is just an action thriller that
happens to have source material that's
printed with pictures and words so if
they can do that with marshalla that's
how you keep that audience happy and
move the story forward and they've
pushed a lot of boundaries with the
midnight suns already i think daredevil
needs to walk that line i think blade
needs to walk that line i think ghost
rider would behoove them to push that
boundary and if you're going to
introduce deadpool i think he's going to
be a character that knows he's in the
mcu i think he's going to be aware that
he came from somewhere else i think he's
going to be like that's interesting and
that allows him to be rated r because
he's not in their universe naturally and
once you break the the barrier of that i
think with she-hulk then she-hulk breaks
the fourth wall ish not fully deadpool
breaks it fully and then you have
characters that are aware of things you
can do already because you've already
broken it out of continuity in
continuity of deadpool does that make
sense well i think i do catch with
because he knows he's rated the universe
he's now in isn't r-rated so he's aware
but that fourth wall break allows our
ready to enter the fold i love that
i think it's gonna be barbie listen
give me an r-rated barbie movie i want
blood i want ryan gosling's head on a
pike
series
some people in the in the chat we've got
a bunch of people saying ghost writer of
course um some people say midnight sons
uh dark avengers would be cool people in
the past have been talking about a
marvel zombies series that they want to
watch philip doesn't want to see that
show i'm in um i also love someone
spector nice's already the heart of the
duck
heck yeah god i'm so bad at that on a
more serious note i think it's going to
be more obvious too listen
i won our reign and more vsts
i know no i know it failed the first
time here's how you fix it more blood
more violence i want jared leto's head
on blood oh lettuce
836 thinks i need eyebrows which i can't
help this is a very bright overstanding
light i'm irish
the lightest
that's all i need i'm saying i look
dumber apparently to charlie here oh we
cleaned out so much of that super chat
can we can we clean out the rest of it
let's get it one uh a t-zone is teasante
i ca i'm sorry i can't read that very
well once the next swear might go to
them okay they want you to swear at them
and again i can't see the left side of
the screen anyone can
uh yeah so we'll run through some of
these super chats real fast uh fragile
our great moderator says anna loves you
koi why are you saying all the right
things he always does john my favorite
short and hoodie wearing pieces thank
you so much skippy cox great name says i
have to drive now you should not be
typing but i love listening to you guys
every day while i'm working love you
guys you're always making my day better
and desantis back he says square up
mccoy and we will honor that request
once we break that barrier thank you um
but first we have other people to thank
oh oh yes we want to thank athletic
greens for well just this right now for
sponsoring the break room today um i'm
gonna let john sort of vanna white it
over here and create create magic in
front of you although i don't know how
we're gonna do that with the cameras but
i'm sure dasha will figure it out so
we've been taking
ag-1 from athletic greens to help boost
our immunity and give us energy
throughout the day the energy we need
with one delicious scoop of ag-1 that's
right one delicious scoop you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods source super foods
i'm so so i am i have a bad record of
dogs
super foods probiotics and adaptogens
usually
you start your day right i should know
what they are because they're in my body
right now this special blend of
ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system your immune system
you got one of those got one of those
your immune system your energy recovery
focus and aging you
might never die but you probably will um
ag-1 has no effect on if you die or not
they certainly won't
cause
anyway john's making this um angel
this is a live show i'm gonna stick to
the script 181 is lifestyle friendly why
don't you eat keto paleo vegan dairy
free or gluten-free or all of the above
what do you eat it supports you has to
keep up with the teleprompter
it supports better sleep quality and
recovery mental clarity which i have
none of an alertness which i have very
little of it's cheaper than getting all
the different supplements yourself you
can't even argue with that don't even
try you're investing
i'm gonna keep going off script so john
can't make it you're investing you're
investing in all-in-one nutritional
insurance state farm i don't think so
agy
everywhere everybody
farm sponsors
and for every franchise
we're okay with you straight farm just
not right now and for every purchase we
donate we donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious food to kids
in need do you know what kids that's why
i saw that cut do you know what kids are
we help getting
to them
including no kid hungry here in the u.s
of gosh darnay right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
it's just one
scoop of water and scoop it a cup of
water every day that's it
there's no need for a million different
pills and supplements to look out for
your health oh my gosh this ad copy just
keeps going to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a
three one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five
free it was all caps and i got worried
about the mic
travel packs with your fur for purchase
all you need to do is visit athletic
greens.com
break room again if you didn't hear the
first time you open up your ears
that's athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional
insurance back to you john
there was a lot of froth on my shake and
i and daschle kept cutting to me
awkwardly shipping out of this well it's
the combo of the outfit and the frogs
i am a jolly green giant it's working
for you i was a i did uh since it was so
overfilled i i
spilled a little bit but look at me my
shorts are just so high so it all fell
on the thigh that's thanks to them in
the chat they uh they made this work
it's too easy being green some might say
you know how in comic books there's the
speech bubble there's also the internal
thought bubble we just got to experience
both versions of that read
simultaneously like i really enjoyed
that you would like break your own
fourth wall and like come back to us boy
if you're learning about the length of
the ad copy and the ads 45 sentences
yeah do you know what kids are
uh if that was if that was hectic to you
that's what happens in my brain at all
times i'm exhausted there's the clip out
john goes it is going to be on an
episode of big question this sunday stay
tuned for more office announcing it
it's a good episode i was listening in
earlier um
hey
uh there's only three of us here today
we're not the normal break room cast but
thank you for being here the reason for
that is because new rock stars is going
to be appearing live in austin texan
live in austin texas this week as part
of the rtx awesome 2020 podcast festival
that is happening from july 1st through
july 3rd and if you've ever wanted to
see some of your favorite new yorkers
host in person now is your chance to
save on a ticket if you're interested in
going click the link in the description
use the promo code new rockstars all one
word and uh this says we hope to see you
there none of us will be there
unfortunately but the people who will be
there
philip molina
uh
dangerous
eric vox scandalous tommy bechtold in
jail uh jessica clements
waiting outside of the jail smoking a
cigarette so that she can flick it at
tommy as soon as he gets out
um so come uh to austin there's gonna be
some uh other new yorkers folks there
that are some kind of behind the scenes
people uh we hope you'll be there we had
a great show in chicago the last time we
did one of these things they don't make
it onto the internet so this will be
your only chance to see some content
that we don't even it won't be like an
episode of the break room or big
question or anything like that it's a
special thing that we do so so get out
there you can buy tickets now
ask them about barbie yeah ask about
barbie you're like philip wants to take
a look yeah
um i spent maybe 90 of my energy on that
ag-1 read thinking that i had a break
coming up here but i don't
know because it's time
for mandatory fun play the graphic
the segment uh
i don't want i don't i said it's so nice
we play it twice buddy
all right director of mrs marble
charming obey chenoy teases what the
next two episodes of mrs marvel will
look like i'm gonna need the chuckling
to stop over here thank
you she says
right we're getting back into it she
says
i take her on this big adventure where
she comes to understand who she is and
where she gets her powers from so wait
hold on before you do that i only
chuckled because i i realized that the
under the the elbow of my legs is very
sweaty because of that
here's the elbow
yeah i have one for my legs hey chat
please name with the elbow of your
an elbow legs give us a give us a name
for that
called is there a knee pit
i'm sorry sweaty um so we we have a
clippy clip oh god i'm kidding
we have a clip of what the next episode
of mrs marvel will look like put a clip
[Music]
[Music]
very strong hideout game
well usually tourists are not allowed
but for a descendant of aishas
i'm sure we can make an exception
how did you know i was my name is waleed
your great-grandmother's story is of
legend when you're ready
we have much to discuss
you got to stop taking your mask off oh
yeah you got to stop taking your mask
off scandalous how did you know your
marriage you lowered your mouth
you showed me your face that's the
soundtrack the soundtrack in the show is
such a bomb mace and m.i.a in the same
episode
so we are going to do some predictions
as to what we may see in the upcoming ms
marvel episode now
maybe neither of them happen but we're
going to choose which is more likely i
will y'all are going to play so
do you understand the rules did i
explain it i understand the rules okay
yeah we we these might be wrong these
might be complete and that's okay
we're we're picking one yes you have to
it's the law so first up which is more
likely who's up to no good the red
dagger or comrade
hmm you're okay i'll go first
i think
qumran will you know sort of end up
being an ally in this in this show uh on
the side of the gym right now presumably
seems to be
not really vibing with them as well um
so i think i think he'll end up being a
good character i'm saying red dagger uh
not good
not good between the two yeah i'm gonna
go with comrade because i feel like he's
going to be torn and he's going to want
to side but then at the end he's going
to choose family and that's going to
betray because we're going to be like
willy won't he and then i think red
dagger is going to be on our side
because the actual like superhero
team-up element i feel like he's
inherently good we just don't trust a
person in a mask ooh i like that i will
say
the best time
i shouldn't say this as if i've done it
before the best time to take advantage
of someone is when they're you know the
most vulnerable and
and kamala has been like wronged by
people that she trusted and now it's
like oh red dagger's coming in being
like don't trust me i'm great look at me
i'm awesome this is also one of those
times like adaptation versus translation
which i talked about earlier is great
because i love this comic book i'm a big
miss marvel fan i think she's one of the
best new characters the last 10 years
this modern age of marvel i think she's
very much like our silver age spider-man
like family and city and protector and
like underdog so i love that i know the
storyline that they've presented me to
this point but i honestly don't know
which way it's going to go because the
show does such a good job like
subverting expectations so here's a
thing where i'm always like but i can't
tell because usually if there's a
character on a show where i'm like i bet
that person's gonna turn out to be bad
because it's like a little too good to
be true i look at how they speak what
their dialogue is when they're not
around the person they could potentially
turn on and so far he's been very
genuinely sort of like with
with her uh and and vulnerable if you
will so if they turn that right around
it's like no it was all trick i was i'll
be like yes not when he was like
probably sharing yeah
i'll call bs but uh hey okay so we have
both of you say the same thing but no
we're opposite oh i said cameron he says
red dagger you say red dagger okay ooh
we'll see are we pulling in chat too yes
let's do it do it okay on to the next
one though which is more likely monica
or carol danvers coming to help her
yeah that's your bad grammar that you're
right you're up first yeah i feel like
in this case we'll get carol danvers
because she's been so heavily alluded to
as her idol i feel like the emotional
impact of monica joining them as the
marvels in the movie will feel more
special if we don't undermine that by
not having carol show up in the show if
that makes sense like she idolizes carol
danvers so that's such a moment that i
feel like belongs to ms marvel the show
that it'll be great when there's another
big moment when spectrum joins her in
the movie so personally i go carol just
because i want an alley-oop of moments
when all three of them get together i
love them
committing to spectrum and not photon as
a name
first of all um
i think
i'm so glad we did not pre-plan this i'm
glad that we're taking opposite sides on
both of these so far
i think
what is a funnier joke
monica rambo showing up
and for um and for combo to be like
she's not because she's not a known
quantity right in the world she'd be
like okay i was really hoping for carol
just like an undercut like ah
i guess this is cool i think the real
question is yeah i know i knew her when
i was a kid the real question is what's
the budget on this one who can who can
get for this one maybe if the bunch is
big enough maybe they start with monica
and then maybe at the very end they're
like boom big guns you're so convinced
that i'm like i'm with you
you're going right into the movie all
right
fair enough okay fine we have our
answers oh did we get an answer from
that last poll yet or is it still is it
still working on it uh 55 are saying
carol danvers uh i think they're going
to show up and who is up to no good we
had 63 say uh red dagger is up to no
good sorry coy
here we are we'll see don't trust a man
in a mask and are we just talking about
like this next episode or are we
overarching uh i think these predictions
are sort of for the next episode but
they you know we might not get these
answers yeah yeah that's fair okay what
is more likely do we think she's cree or
jin that's difficult because technically
could be both right um
and and we left and human off of this
list for a reason i think like either
that's too obvious or marvel has sort of
said like we're not doing that um
i i would love for her to be cree
because that would set up some really
interesting dynamics in the marvels
right we know that this pre-scroll war
is on the horizon we know obviously
carol danvers has a big problem with
cree
and is now sort of like um in the corner
of
of the scroll side of this this conflict
um so that would be very interesting set
up and i think the gin whole the whole
gin thing might just be a smoked screen
i don't know if anyone is jim oh wow i
think the gin thing is a smoke screen
and it kind of ties into that earlier
like we're expanding so much mythology i
feel like at least one of them has to be
kind of like
not quite what it's being presented as
so i think the creek could be gin or the
gin could be inhuman which i know we've
left off on purpose but i do feel like
the gin
arcrey or inhuman i don't feel like it's
its own thing in this universe so what's
what i'm leaning for the sake of uh
argument okay
uh it looks like uh cree is is leading
with fifty two percent yeah it's tight
oh it's tight it's so tight speaking of
tight i want john to hike up his shorts
some more can we get
like
tight hamstrings that's what i was
talking about uh all right so which is
more likely when kamala uses her power
next will she get the vision of aisha or
the train
that's tough
right
uh aisha coming through and being like
i'ma get you would be crazy right that
would be super cool if she has another
vision and it's aisha being like you're
am i getting my characters correct i
think so um
that would be very cool uh but the train
obviously we need a lot more backstory
on so that's it it could be either i'm
leaning aisha since we're gonna stay
contrarian i i could have an argument
for either but i'm gonna go train for
the sake of like we're on episode four
the show's usually formatted in act
structure so the first act was the first
two episodes the second act is where
we're still living and the second act
needs to get
enough exposition to build to the climax
so i think they're going to save aisha
for the climactic battle so that'll be
more phase you know i mean episode five
stuff i'ma go train so we get a little
bit more family before we get conflict
yeah so story i do love getting more
trained and i think like we talked about
this a little bit right after we watched
episode three last week that like okay
kamala's grandmother also saw this
vision of the train kamala's mother
probably saw this vision of the train
you know you've got to think her great
grandmother got pushed in front of a
train at some point and we're going to
get answers to that so whether it's in a
vision or a flashback we're definitely
going to see it again um but i think in
terms of the vision it would be
interesting if like
you know someone was breaking through
right yeah people are screaming more
trained more that's what the people want
we love a train um
we're super excited miss marvel episode
two excuse me episode four comes out at
midnight tonight you know that's what
we're gonna be talking about tomorrow on
the break room um but um usually on
wednesdays we've been talking about oh
the obi-wan now that that has sort of
sunsetted we're getting some really
interesting news from some of the
creators of obi-wan um and with our last
couple minutes here i want to sort of go
through uh an interview with stuart
beede who was sort of i don't know if
you guys know about the story uh this
series was originally conceived of as a
film
and uh after solo came out lucasfilm
sort of
re-strategized and wanted to focus more
on series and so they ended up expanding
it from a two-hour film to a six-hour
series right and and stewart was the
person who wrote that original film and
he has credits for episodes one two and
three of obi-wan as well as the finale
because that's sort of like interesting
you know that's sort of like what the
movie was and then episodes four and
five were sort of like extra um
but he just gave a really interesting
interview um that
um
you know he was sort of like i wrote
this one film and they really liked it
um and
the folks at lucasfilm said we actually
think there's enough story here for two
more films they were planning on making
this a trilogy of of films and um so he
says so yeah i spent like a year year
and a half working on it and then when
the decision was made to not make any
more spin-off films i left the project
to work on other things
um
so he says the original pitch was three
stories the first story was what we got
from the show the second story this is
what's really interesting to me was
thinking about where kenobi ends up up
to when he sacrifices himself in a new
hope uh he says you know he has to come
to terms with his mortality uh getting
to a point where he accepts he's going
to die and die willingly so when the
moment comes up in a new hope you
understand and it's a real tear jerker
so you know
to me that says if we do get a second
and a maybe a third season of obi-wan
kenobi it's gonna be sort of dealing
with
you know kenobi's acceptance in his
place in this universe rather than you
know this first season which was like
him having to accept like i have to let
luke be luke
and you know
or else things are going to go poorly
for that kid and i'll take care of this
conflict over here um so it i guess my
question for you guys is if we do get a
season two of kenobi which after some of
these interviews it seems likely
what sort of you know
kenobi in the cave meditation story do
you kind of want to see is that
interesting
i personally would love to leave the
skywalkers alone for five minutes yeah i
like it's a galaxy far far away not a
street and we've lived with these same
people and i know kenobi we've lived
with but ewen mcgregor's kenobi i feel
like is so interesting in a way that
isn't just involving the skywalkers i'd
love to see his kind of meditations on
the jedi because we've seen the jedi as
this allegory for certain conventions of
religion certain conventions of warrior
and certain conventions and all these
things and in a way we haven't really
gotten to explore the jedi we've had
them as a tool but not a source of
knowledge right so i would love to
actually see the jedi
the fleshed-out version of the jedi that
we get in the books that we get in the
comics that we get in the folklore
that's talked about but never shown so
give me a meditation and let me have a
vader show and a kenobi show separate
give me vader season one kenobi season
two get to this point and then let me
earn kenobi evolving to the master that
he's implied to be i do think there's so
much more fun on the vader side of
things than there is on the commander
commander the kenobi side of things um
but you know we don't know what story
they want to tell with with kenobi i'll
ask you this too we had book of boba
fett come out that could have been maybe
a film do we like the direction that
that um lucasfilm is taking with these
series
um
you know
i would say like
i just love that we're getting star wars
content we're getting star wars content
consistently
um and like
if we get series we just get to spend
more time with our favorite characters i
i honestly had been kind of tagged out
of star wars because the fandom had
gotten like mad at me uh and i felt like
i went to star wars celebration i
remember what it was about like i saw
star wars fans in person i saw the
revelry i saw the love i saw like what
it meant to be in the world and i'm
fully back yeah so i had been like i
didn't even watch book about until after
celebration because i was like i'm done
like i was like i'm checked out but i
was so invested in how much passion the
fandom had in person that i was like
okay this is worth the keyboard cowboys
so i'm back to the point where like i
want all of it but i want it to feel
earned and special enough which is why i
want kenobi to feel like a jedi story i
want whatever tyke is doing to feel
unique and different because i do feel
like the way we get burnt out is if we
let fans steer the ship and they only
get what they want that's forever going
to be nostalgia recycling so i think we
go new ground i will say i'm really
excited for both tyka's uh movie and
john watson's show yeah this kevin feige
michael waldron movie so um you know i
think there's room for both of these
things and i'm i'm glad they're going
back to movies in a way but i i love
that we're doing series as well i'm a
theater guy like the exhibition world i
love going to the theater i love the
experience of the movies but i people
that are met at the show just don't
watch them yeah like it's that simple
then just go to the movies once every
two years like you we fought to get
these once every 10 years and now you
get the months every two don't watch the
show
hi
anna vanston here resident star wars
expert of the team and uh maybe
president of the star wars fan club just
want to give my two cents real quick
kenobi what a guy right i think i'm on
the same page with what you said about
the skywalkers but either way i think i
think they're really gonna fit the
director's vision and i'm not gonna say
anything either way for sure but me
thinks c3po might be somewhere on the
horizon maybe you might have a little
bit of a comeback back to you john
speaking of kevin feige i'm gonna say
what's the political change um do you
think that the upcoming babu frick show
is gonna be live up to the expectations
oh babou never disappoints except when
they do you know okay fair enough um a
real question is
uh we sort of heard some reports that uh
darth maul was gonna be sort of a
central villain in this kenobi show and
that ended up getting changed we think
that that could be something that we see
in season two or do you think we'll just
have some sort of like internal or
external threat that we aren't currently
aware of i don't think we're gonna do
vader and kenobi again in the second
season right
someone say yes and someone say no and i
can see both sides honestly i think both
have uh valuable answers to them
what are your thoughts on this
i i would personally prefer instead of
the same story of lone wolf and cub to
have a revenge story that way it gives
us the the he's already felt kind of
redemption for what he experienced with
anakin like he got his comparisons i
would love to see the antithesis of that
where he's got his closure on one story
homeboy doesn't have closure on him so
like bring back spider like most and i
want sam to get some work
is that the right point at the time like
that'd be very wouldn't it be i guess
yeah so like i would have sam come back
and i'd have spider-like maul and have
some revenge i would enjoy him being
like i am at peace with being a jedi oh
no and that's what i'd do
yeah um we have a couple more minutes
since we started a little bit late today
i want to get to some of your great
super chats f theodore harris says how
will the 10 rings be connected to the
bangle if at all we did a little bit of
speculating on the channel that you know
okay why is tara so important in
uh the mcu there's it's just a bunch of
people um maybe it's because there was a
cree scroll war that had already
happened on this planet and there were
some artifacts left over do we think
that the bengal from miss marvel and the
ten rings from chongqi will have any
relation to one another
these are life's toughest questions
i hate how you lean back every time
i don't want to over talk
can i have
one more swear please i'm just begging
you before the end of the show
this is also
murray in the mix is also asking about
uh miss marvel and mcu links and i am
assuming when they say links they're
talking about the thin rings
um i think they all talk no one's got
any barbie questions they all tie into
eternally i think eternals is the
beginning of all of this i think a
certain creator that we met in eternals
makes a lot of these things that allow
us to move forward with artifacts uh i
mean we met brian tyree henry and we saw
what he made a lot of those things
looked a lot like the same stylistic
choice and i think that it might not be
the ten rings directly but i think it
might be like a family of artifacts and
i think that the kris gul war is going
to be not the first war they've had so i
think we see through the eternals who
are supposed to be very integral to this
phase of the mcu a cree scroll will
already happen on earth maybe we see the
eternals they are dealing with it and
those artifacts come from that war and
then when we get to secret invasion that
ties directly into both marvel and the
eternals do you think that we'll see
right yeah
i love that you know perhaps the
uh ten rings were not mcluhan tech they
were they were uh eternal tech i think
that'd be rad do you think that we'll
see
uh
more
of these artifacts yeah from that time
period and and other super powered
beings sort of popping up as as like
vulture was sort of scavenging for
things after the battle of new york we
could just see some sort of like people
doing so i would love like an indiana
jones series where people are like i
gotta find some magical artifacts think
about moon knight with artifacts think
about like what we've seen so far is for
the gathering powers and i think it's a
really interesting way to not have
everything be like bitten by a spider
you know like it's a it's an interesting
way to enhance and i also think that she
might be powered and that opens it up
like instead of the terrigen mists or
what about in conjunction with the
terrorism mists they allow her to be a
thing so i i do think there's going to
be more artifacts to come
i don't necessarily but what if that's
the you know supplement yeah like what
if that thing awakens it yeah i think
there's gonna be more artifacts i like
that a lot um
well
we've got a couple more super chats that
i want to get to uh
pear trap 124 says koi i saw you on the
red carpet live stream for thor 4
which movies would you suggest
refreshing on before going to see it i
got one of the best dressed i got i
think they did the best dress section i
was on that list
that's why they saw him in the live
stream thank you uh i
i hated what you were wearing i know my
pulled my pulses did too
it wasn't this short
uh i would recommend watching um thor
thor two thor three uh perhaps infinity
thor and four game uh i'd watch i would
watch if you're gonna watch a lead up uh
i think it's safe to assume um the man
this is hard uh i think it's safe to
assume the things you think are involved
are involved
so you know uh we don't need to go back
and watch winter soldier it's probably
fine yeah you're probably good maybe you
don't have to watch ant-man too i don't
know no you can't stop me
if you want to my homies this is a
question for anna only oh cool um
why do you think they're chasing oh that
was that was a question we asked in the
champ the chat
oh this is like why why are they chasing
people's theories someone says um
why do we think they're chasing barbie
maybe barbie and ken are spit spreading
so much joy the suits are trying to be
party poopers
i think
and then michael humphries is definitely
an ultimate roller skate tournament i
would love it if for some reason uh
uh will ferrell's character was
sort of like luca but they have to like
enter themselves into that race at the
end of the movie i was like i gotta get
my black roller skates out to compete in
this race oh i want to see scroll i want
to see what joe jamski said
scroll
he's cut off what does it say oh yeah
it's on the left side barbie is going to
be the existential struggle to find the
meaning in life i don't know i don't
necessarily disagree with that i'm
telling it's gonna be a a life-size
moment she needs to learn about
the joy of i don't womanhood what's the
metaphor she needs to learn what it is
to be alive and i think that you think
barbie needs to learn see i think
barbie's gonna be the teacher what but i
think no i think both ways i think she
needs to learn how to exactly
we love it both ways story i think
yeah it's me talking to my coworkers
about star wars brian sandler sent a 20
super chat said love you guys please
come back again uh will you guys swear
it then while i go put on another layer
yeah
it's really high i'll be right back i
don't know how to swear at t saints
because they seem very nice oh yes you
have a life
yeah i was on a mission okay it's t
i believe t-z-a-n-t-e
uh
desanti when i say that you are so
palpably [ __ ] fine
i love you dang
i felt like a compliment because they
like contributed
no it's great swears can work
complementarily you can passionately
swear at some point i think that feels
better um which is what i will do right
now as i try to contain my excitement
for what's happening behind me i got the
biggest shirt that i could find oh
that's nice
and i'm getting the shortest short okay
oh we're getting tucked in the boxes
kids
thank you guys so much for watching the
break room today we're going to be here
tomorrow and on thursday talking about
miss marvel and love and thunder and you
we're know on friday because we're gonna
be
uh in austin um
but that just means our thursday show is
gonna be the wild one so stay tuned for
the whole week coy will be back tomorrow
anna will be back tomorrow um we're
gonna have a ton of fun uh thank you
guys so much for watching we'll see you
tomorrow love ya